in 2017 Google created seven AI
principles to help us build AI
applications responsibly now let me show
you how they're used in vertex Ai and
Jet app builder to help you build
responsibly with generative AI on Google
Cloud whether you are training a model
in vertex AI or building a customer
service experience on gen app builder
private data is kept private you control
where the data is stored or how or if it
is used so you can obey regulations and
data sovereignty laws while you build
awesome stuff vertex Ai and gen app
builder include tools to inspect
understand and modify the behavior of
your models providing transparency and
explainability gen app builder uses
information retrieval algorithms to
provide the right sourcing and
attribution while serving the most
relevant information maintaining what we
call factuality and freshness that lets
you blend the interactive and
probabilistic nature of generative AI
with results that are controlled
deterministic and reliable you can read
more about our AI principles here